[Music]
hello everybody welcome thanks for
coming
this is your first session so I hope
you're awakened by now we're gonna talk
today about the editing advanced
security to the mix we're gonna talk
that today about some trends that you're
observing
I'm gonna talk today about the why did
we leave Syria smash is important
my name is Dima Boyer and I'm here with
my esteemed colleague Vinay Venkat our
Gavin good try some would say Bonet
Venkat Raghavan some good morning and
we're gonna try to explain you what do
we do here at Palo Alto Networks and why
we think it is important so before we
start with this if you can just give me
a little bit with a raise of hands how
many of you is actually familiar with
the sto thank you how many of you are
actually there may be something other
than Easter in history smash and the
last one is that how many of you
actually have to have security sanction
your abs before they can be deployed in
production you know today talk about the
are containers and micro-services trends
we're gonna tell you about why some of
it is complex and things that you have
to worry about that we observed we're
going to talk about one implementation
the series smash Easter which is
arguably probably the most predominant
out there we will talk about some
importance in advantages of it some
pitfalls and we're gonna do then explain
you guys how we saw Saudis with our
peril the network's history of solution
and then at the end we're gonna have a a
demo time to how it will actually just
together so back in the days you are all
familiar with the monolithic
applications you know you had usually
three-tier model are mainly done with a
presentation model and the some kind of
middle of air and then persistence model
or storage there was very understandable
between these three components there
were summer decoupled but yet they were
very static back in the days so really
you know although we claim this is
decoupling in a three-tier architecture
our relations were very known understood
well what comes next
we came up with a series mesh we came
with a we came with micro services
became you the containers so now
containers are just the current trend in
that gets you the helps you get to the
applications you know but they helped us
actually kind of decoupled even more our
services get more performance out of
them deal with the scalability
reliability and actually make things a
little bit easier and so or so we
thought because what we figured out as
you deploy your monolithic applications
into this sort of micro services
architecture you really have to
understand relations between these
services some of them are very related
to each other some in an unrelated some
of them have to scale really quickly
some of them you know you don't care
much about they're much more static you
need to understand how closely do they
live to each other so they can deal with
the latency issues you have to figure
out what's it atomic serious component
you gotta worry about or how narrow do
you need to go with each of your
services so there's other questions you
get to ask yourself before you deploy
micro services so now deploying micro
spheres itself is very easy you know
everybody that did any development can
probably figure out very quickly how to
deploy the Service micro service or how
to develop one what wasn't easy figuring
out all the other relations between them
you know let's look security in monolith
architecture security is more or less
known you're gonna put your security
principles mainly right perimeter your
choke points what do you do micro
services I mean there is really no
perimeter anymore it's kind of be
solving you talking about north-south in
a melodic architecture
in microservices here talk about
north-south and east-west and up and
down and left and right so what do you
do with it how do you figure this out
what we figured out is that actually
building those microservices is easy but
to build em right is actually really
hard so now imagine a world in which
actually micro-services are secured
imagine the world in which a agility of
your DevOps is not impeded by your
security teams but it doesn't take two
weeks to approve the application that
you can develop every day and the
updates every day and release every day
so this is the world we kind of live
every day in Palo Alto Networks coming
from the security side of things
especially enterprise security
enterprise security doesn't move that
quickly it's actually super slow it
actually slows down their ops teams so
how to combine these two these two two
things together is a question and we're
gonna show how to do that
so now as micro services were maturing
more and more you know there were some
other frameworks and components which
allowed us to actually easy out of some
of the job you know starting with the
kubernetes number one Orchestrator out
there you know it's very helpful in
deploying and orchestrating your
applications it helps you with lifecycle
management it helps you with scaling out
scaling down it does all the health
checks for you developers don't have to
worry about it
however it's like a little bit in a
network security policies because it
does have some however those are usually
at the layer 3 layer 4 supports
basically 5 topples right well serviced
meshes came in and service meshes came
in to actually help with complexity of
the networking and topology in route
but also they also came in to kind of
figure out how to solve some of the
security issues
sto arguably are probably the number one
implementation of the series meshes
decided to kind of figure out if you
know effect help you with a routing
we're gonna help you with security
however they just defined the framework
around security they let you implement
it yourself to figure out how they wanna
deal with it you know on a Left screen
shatter screen this is adjusted with
ability into the Twitter micro services
architecture you can google it it's all
over the place I mean that does look
easy how do you apply security that some
of them would like to call this service
mess not series smash so it's really
charging problem Soviet pull out the
network's look at this and try to figure
out how actually can we help how we can
bring enterprise-grade security into the
series smashes and there are a couple of
ways we decide we're gonna go along this
we figure out we need to bring our high
level grade security in a series mesh so
you gotta be unified it should feel the
same you should definitely do the same
thing that we do everywhere else we
figure out the visibility is very
important because if you don't see
what's going in your Interpol Interpol
traffic you know how can you know what's
really going on in your network these
are all blind spots you know some of the
other services like Suri smashes they
can help you with some of that but they
only know what they know so the set of
the protocols their support is very
limited and the worst thing is that
really done knowing what you don't know
which means you don't have visibility
over things that serious measures can
see so we can help with that and on top
of it obviously there is security for
ingress egress and intermesh itself
so with all of that said don't know give
microphone to Rene so you tell us how do
you actually do this okay great
hopefully great thanks a lot everyone
and thanks even you know when we asked
you guys how many of you are adopting
history oh it was great to see most of
you raised your hand so it looks like
I'm gonna be not preaching but speaking
to the choir here but let's take a pause
and figure out you know why we're doing
this right so we talked about how
micro-services are dominating
predominant production architectures
today but why are we doing that right
and when I try to answer that question I
think it's primarily it's driven by
agility right because enterprises need
to deploy their applications they need
to be allowed the users to access those
applications and they need to get it
there needs to be a very tight feedback
loop right consequently your developers
need to move very very fast right so
let's talk about then if we are
proposing the industry as a whole you
know there are service measures and
architecture and sto in particular how
does he still help that perspective
right you know you're developers now
have the ability to reason about your
applications as code everything is s
code kubernetes and they still allow you
to reason about your infrastructure less
code now you see how that agility is
facilitated however and I'm gonna caveat
my next statement by saying I am a
developer but I straddle both worlds you
know developers are not the most
security-conscious I mean they are
working on a very very tight timeline so
they need to develop and deploy code
very very fast so it is up to the
security teams to enforce best practices
make sure that their deployments are
secure so so from the first perspective
so the developers now have the ability
to deploy all their applications and
they can use kubernetes and sto
primitives to actually connect their
services ensure discoverability and
ensure that their services are actually
usable now I've spoken to many many
security practice practitioners out
there and I also saw some of some of you
raise their hands
these applications can never see the
light of day until it's sanctioned by
their security teams and I can and I've
already had a chatted a few of you here
who can validate that right so what does
easier do to provide that right so steel
actually allows you to give abstract out
fundamental services that your
development team that your applications
absolutely need so let's talk about what
they are right encryption you need
encryption between your services you
need mutual TLS you need authentication
and a host a variety of services that
are required by each and every
application so now you can see how this
Foster's secure provides security but
also fosters agility by abstracting out
these services and your development
teams can now focus on their job at hand
which is the line of business
application right so steel provides
these primitives by giving you these
capabilities and allowing you to enforce
these capabilities with zero changes to
your code and I think that's a very
that's a win-win situation so now let's
talk about really briefly before we get
into the really meat of this
presentation but how does he still do
this right so steel is fundamentally
comprised of three three major services
one is pilot the other one is mixer and
one the other one that the last one but
not least a citadel so we're going to
focus on the mixer architecture here
today but I want to quickly just round
out the value proposition provided by
pilot this is what allows you to connect
your services allow you to do the
traffic management load balancing
service discovery etc right and Citadel
allows you to distribute certificates to
make sure that your applications are
authenticated and also use the necessary
encryption so having said that let's get
into how what what the services provided
by mixer are and how we can leverage
that to provide a deep security for all
your applications running on kubernetes
with Misty Oh
so this slide is talks about the mixer
architecture I wanted to quickly go over
it and describe the salient aspects of
this to your right to the right of the
screen
fundamentally it's all
hinges upon the envoy proxy so typical
deployments in a part which is the
fundamental unit of work in a kubernetes
environment is the fact that there's
always an envoy proxy that fronts your
application so envoy is the one that
actually has a very rich set of
attributes that it uses to actually
expose an API which is called the XDS
API to control planes such as sto that
can leverage this data and provide
value-added services so then let's dig
deeper into the mixer architecture
essentially mixer is a rules engine and
it's comprised at a very very high level
at the risk of simplifying it too much
by three different components right so
you have a set of rules that defines
exactly what actions need to be taking
place you know what actions is to a
mixer needs to take place in order to
facilitate integration with adapters
that are supported what an instance is
to say hey what is this information that
I need to send when I whenever when a
rule is matched and then it's also
comprised of these adapters so I also
wanted to showcase the fact that when
you deploy mixer and eesti or today
there are you get a lot of inbuilt
adapters that are built into the whole
ISTE of framework which provide lots of
value-added services so allows you to
perform some kind of auerbach allows you
to integrate a lot of telemetry into
backends such as Prometheus but I also
want to highlight that now we have built
a security adapter for mixer and we are
the first vendor to build a security
adapter for mixer I'm very happy to make
that announcement today so what we have
done is we're going to bring we're going
to leverage these capabilities provided
by sto in general so envoy actually
surfaces to API calls one is a check API
call and one is a report API call and I
think you can see how we actually
progress with this the check api call is
used to enforce policy across your
service mesh and then the report api
call is used to learn to surface a lot
of fine grained
entry and information about traffic
patterns that are traversing your
network so having laid the groundwork
for this mixer architecture let's get
into how exactly palo alto leverages
this kind of a framework to provide this
kind of deep security for containerized
workloads so before we get into that I
also wanted to talk about a certain
pitfall blind blind spot right so what
you see here is a subset of the sto
attribute vocabulary so what that is
these are the information that is
surfaced by the Envoy proxies that can
be leveraged for different use cases
right but what I wanted to highlight
here is the fact that you know we're all
coming from an enterprise world where we
think IP addresses are very very
important we have applications static
applications that don't change much so
we can leverage and hook off of the IP
address however in a micro-services well
things are changing very very rapidly
you have a large number of services so I
just wanted to point out the fact that
IPs don't mean much in this kind of a
work it means a lot from a networking
perspective but not from a security
perspective so we're going to show you
how this is what we talked about
uploading up leveling the the framework
provided by sto to provide fine-grained
security where now we focus on you know
transforming for example palo alto
network security policies and map it
into namespaces services application IDs
etc so the first integration that we
have built out using is TOS to leverage
the the report api surface by envoy and
sto to show fine-grain telemetry about
all accesses that are going on in your
service mesh so we now map this back to
the attribute vocabulary so we can tell
you which source namespace that US that
a request came from what was the source
service what was the HTTP verbs what was
the action what was the what were the
parameters for that connection such as
was encryption enabled was a mutual TLS
etc so this is very very significant
information and I'm actually going to
give you a story that I actually even
real experience yesterday about the
benefits of this capability right and if
you don't have visibility into the
traffic patterns of your environment I
think it's it's a recipe for disaster
so what we have done is we have actually
hooked our security adapter which is now
called the next-generation firewall
policy engine to source information from
envoy and mixer and actually integrate
all that data all the application logs
and metrics into the Palo Alto Networks
cortex derelict we have built out this
adapter as a highly plug-in system so
consequently we have also the first
initial integration that we have also
done is with Google's tag driver so all
of this information is now aggregated
into a single unified console and now
you're able to reason about all your
application patterns what's going on and
now as you can see where we can use this
information to troubleshoot and also
make sure that your applications are
behaving as they should be so the data
source for all of this information is
envoy we harvest all of the data and
aggregate it into the Palo Alto Networks
cortex data Lake so here is a slide that
gives you a sense of exactly we have a
lot of data going but gives you an idea
as to exactly what that data looks like
so you and this is a this is a subset as
you can imagine we can surface all the
attributes that envoy exposes but to
give you an idea so you have a time
stamp you have a severity level of that
the logging what was the source service
that initiated that particular
connection you have the destination
service you have source IP so you have a
wealth of information that you can use
to reason about exactly what's going on
in your network and this is highly
configurable so you can actually expose
as much data or as little to suit your
specific use case and purpose right and
for convenience sake what we've also
done is we have provided all of this
information as a JSON blob that you can
actually query and perform post
analytics and other use cases to
facilitate whatever you need to achieve
so once again what are these benefits
right so this kind of a posture gives
you a record of all your containers
action regardless of container lifetime
so that's very very important because as
you can imagine in the traditional world
where let's say that there was an
exploit or a vulnerability you could
actually go in and perform forensics
because that entity is actually
available there on your network it's not
gone anywhere but containers are highly
ephemeral so if an exploit has happened
I mean that asset is gone it's no longer
there but you need to have a record of
exactly what was going on and the
circumstances around that particular
exploit or a vulnerability to be able to
reason about what exactly happened so
you have now a record of exactly what
happened and what is the use case there
so you can now conduct forensics armed
with full data and to actually figure
out what happens and now you can
actually improve your security posture
so now you can also you also have the
ability to map your container activities
to malicious campaigns you can index and
integrate this something that we have
I'm gonna get dinged for this from by
Palo Alto but from as a roadmap item
we're actually going to integrate this
with our threat Intel cloud and we can
actually map these activities to
potential malicious campaigns so that's
an incredible benefit and it can also
may use that information to enforce the
right policies on your deployments and
last but not least it's highly useful to
perform security lifecycle review and
assessments to say hey what's my posture
what are the applications going what are
the circumstances are they are they
secured what are the conditions are on
these applications and can I actually
sanction these right so those are a lot
of the benefits and that's the first use
case which is visibility into all
aspects of your container deployments
the second use case and the integration
that we perform is policy enforcement
for service measures on kubernetes using
Sto so I'm gonna walk you through a
sequence of slides to show how Palo Alto
has natively integrated with its Tio's
capabilities and the security framework
to give you this fine-grained security
posture so Palo Alto has a product
called panorama which is our management
platform so the Palo Alto the panorama
as a plugin that knows that
can interact with kubernetes clusters to
extract applications labels
microservices etc so this is the
discovery piece where we discover all
the services that are running on your
coburn a DS environment and we displayed
that on our panorama interface once that
is done we can actually deploy our
security adapter onto your kubernetes /e
steo deployments to actually retrieve
the first thing that this security
adapter does this it retrieves these
policies that a user now has actually
defined on panorama so the workflow
there is that user has a single unified
security posture where they discover on
the panorama platform all the services
that are running and they can actually
script security policies on our
management platform to define what are
the sanctioned services and interactions
between their containers what the panel
but what the Palo Alto Networks security
adapter now does is it retrieves these
policies from panorama and actually
transforms them so I will spend a few
minutes in a later slide but we actually
transform this is what I said so now you
have a unified posture where you can
define security policies and we actually
transform them to sto policies and make
it actionable across your service mesh
so for example what does this policy
look like right so you can say hey I
need my front-end my web application
which is running in my front-end
namespace it can access the application
the application tier running in the app
tier namespace on a specific port and a
specific application ID similarly this
gives you can construct security
policies that allow access between
different namespaces and different
services right so what we now do is then
what happens is anytime that so before I
get into how so this is like a typical
microservices deployment you have four
micro services here you have a website
web micro service and application micro
service DB and a pub sub in this
particular instance the web micro
service wants to talk to the application
micro service so the Envoy proxy when
that happens actually performs a check
call to the Palo Alto
network security adapter to say hey I
have the web web service in the
front-end namespace that wants to access
the app service running in the app tier
namespace on this protocol with this
particular application ID so the the
security adapter now has retrieved all
these policies and performed this
transformation and now it can say yep I
have an entry it matches I can actually
allow this this particular connection to
go through so as you can see the web
service is not allowed to talk to the
application service consequently you
know where the next slide is going let's
say that your web service gets exploited
and there is a vulnerability and
somebody has been able to attack that
particular application or container so
suddenly you have your web service
trying to access your DB tier which is
arguably unsanctioned because only the
application service can access the DB
tier this is where your critical data
resides so this is this is unsanctioned
so similarly however envoy will actually
make the call to the Palo Alto Networks
adapter to say hey I have this kind of
an applicant pattern access happening is
this sanction clearly it's not because
we don't have any rule which says that
the web service in the front-end
namespace can actually access the DB
tier so consequently this is this access
is denied also want to point out that
all of this even this even the policy
enforcement piece they are all logged
into both Star Driver and the cortex
data like for you to reason about so all
of these are available - for
post-processing
so this slide here gives you an idea as
to exactly how that that logging looks
like so you can see that you have the at
the top you can see that the mixer sent
a check request to the Palo Alto network
security adapter and we actually
performed a lookup and you can see that
there were certain micro services in
different namespaces accessing the
access different different destination
services and it goes through it performs
a lookup and it'll actually also show
you whether that request was a
or denying right so just to recap this
what are the benefits right you have
consistent policy definition as you can
see it's a unified single single entity
that security teams need to define their
policies and then seamlessly apply these
kinds of Palo Alto network security
policies for example and actually
transform them to make them actionable
across your container workloads in
different environments for either
kubernetes on-premise or even your vm
workloads so as I mentioned it also
translates Palo Alto Networks security
policies to kubernetes and sto policies
and then as I already mentioned this
consisting logging and feedback loop I
just want to spend maybe a minute
talking about how exactly we transform
these policies as I'm gonna show you in
the demo so that you have the right
context there Palo Alto Networks is
trying to be as cloud native and as
container native as possible and one of
the artifacts that we're able to
leverage is a concept called dynamic
address groups which is a very versatile
scaleable solution so what we do is for
all your namespaces we allow our users
to define dynamic address groups add dag
tags as I call it the tags represent all
the different services that have been
discovered on your from your kubernetes
environments we add the source services
let's say that we know that the web tier
needs to talk to the application tier so
we will add all the services which form
the source which are initiating
connections to the source dynamic
address group similarly we add all the
destination services to the destination
dynamic address group we add all of
these data tags and this is how we can
translate the Palo Alto network security
policy into history of policies and I'll
show you exactly how that comes into
play so before we get into the demo
another salient aspect of this solution
is the fact that we can now use a
unified security posture that is
panorama and actually apply security
policies provide the visibility across
heterogeneous environments so for
example you can have an open shift
kubernetes cluster running on your
on-prem and open shipped uses STO for
their
policy enforcement and traffic
management capabilities we can obviously
run on gke are running on your GCP cloud
the managed kubernetes provided by
google and we can and last but not least
we can also seamlessly run this kind of
a posture using GAE running on your
on-premise environments so all of these
entities as you can see will
fundamentally consists of obviously
kubernetes
and we will use the panorama plugin will
actually harvest the kubernetes labels
discover services provide that single
pane for discovery of all your services
across all of these different
environments on a single unified console
for example we will then the users the
operators will then define security
policies which can be highly automated
everything that you do with the Palo
Alto Networks devices are all API driven
and you can actually deploy all your
policies onto panorama and have them
push to the next generation firewall
policy engine that's the name of our
security adapter that's available on the
Google marketplace I'm gonna talk about
that across all your different
environments and as you can see you can
you can now have all the data visible in
your cortex data leak and I also
mentioned I'm also going to show you how
we actually aggregate all of the data
into stack driver as well so you can use
a unified platform to now have a secure
posture across different heterogeneous
environments and that's an incredible
value that we see and why is this
important is the fact that I've spoken
to many operators many enterprises I
mean we are on this container journey
but it's not gonna happen overnight what
we typically see is you have your
systems of engagement that are
potentially going to be running on your
kubernetes workloads and you're in the
cloud for example but they are going to
be accessing critical data that is
resident in your databases potentially
in your on-prem environments so it's
very critical that you be able to have a
unified posture to secure all these
different environments because this is
where Palo Alto came from as well by the
way you can't have too many tools I mean
you have it that's that's there's a huge
learning curve I mean that's that's also
not a recipe for
so having a unified security posture
that you can actually apply across all
these different environments is very
important so I want to showcase the fact
that the palo alto network security
solution is it's brand spanking new we
there were a number of announcements
that went out yesterday it's available
on the google marketplace and now you
can actually deploy the solution
directly onto your gke clusters running
in the on GCP or in on 2gk on pranaam
i'm going to demo both of these so as
you can see here from your google
console you can see two clusters the
fact that the one is indicated as
external on the top means that that's an
on-prem cluster so you can actually from
the google marketplace you can deploy
the solution across both your on-prem
and your cloud running on GCP GK on GCP
and then event do you have something to
say about this point so number one at
any point of time you don't have to deal
with the IP addresses all that magic
happens underneath so you already only
deal with the labels kubernetes labels
which you're familiar with right the
secondly like you know as you as I
showed you before like you don't have to
worry about that these containers are
deployed as far as they're labeled
correctly like web service or otherwise
we can set up policies for those so your
developers as far as they label them or
they have a prescribed way or how to
label their containers if they
developing web service or developing the
the persistent storage or something like
that you know as a micro service that's
all what I have to do security teams
will just apply policies automatically
on top of it so you have to have any
calls you don't have open a service now
requests you have to do anything just
deploy it label it and security follows
yeah now that's a great point because
another thing another trend that Yvonne
is pointing out is the fact that
developers need that agility I mean
we've always hearing the fact that
security teams are impeding that agility
but what if we can now have a but but
security is a table stake what if we can
now show you how that it can be a
win-win situation Africa actually
security can have a very
lightweight posture that really doesn't
impede the agility that is required from
your developers in the development team
and it doesn't take away a control from
security teams I mean they're gonna work
for us anyway but they can work together
I think that's very important yeah all
right so we've spoken a lot so far let's
see hopefully we can surface how all of
this works in action and I'm going to
there's a cop out here I wasn't going to
challenge the demo gods but I think
Google has done a phenomenal job with
their Wi-Fi infrastructure but having
said that I'm still going to run this
video and if you could stick with me we
will oops
we can I'll walk you through this video
and show you how exactly we pull all of
these concepts that we've talked about
together I'm going to stand here because
I'm gonna drive the video from here so
what we're starting off here is the
Google console and I want to show the
fact that we have multiple clusters that
we have deployed here and now we're
actually going to showcase all the
artifacts that have been deployed on
these clusters these are existing
clusters and a highlight of the solution
is the fact that as you can see now
let's say a common use case as our
developers have gone ahead and said hey
I need to use kubernetes I need to run
all my application this is the posture
that we need and then the security team
comes in and says hey what's going on
right I need to know what's going on so
these are existing clusters and we're
gonna showcase how this lightweight
posture that security can actually be
layered on without inhibiting the
developer agility so what you see over
here is the fact that we have a very
common popular micro service application
rather that's been defined
it's got n number of micro services for
example the carts is the micro service
each one as a deployment it's also a
service so you can see that there are 10
or 15 micro services that have been
deployed onto this cluster
so what we're going to now show you is
how we unboard these clusters into
panorama panorama is the Palo Alto
Networks management platform and we use
that to onboard these clusters and what
happens when these clusters are on
boarded is that they actually query the
kubernetes api and and perform a
discovery so as you can see here we have
discovered that there are at a high
level there are four services for
example so you see the front-end service
you see as shipping service and orders
and a payment so this goes back to the
fact that you're in this single pane you
can discover all the services that are
running across in number of clusters
existing clusters across different
deployments that you have on kubernetes
so we have a second cluster and we're
also going to show you how we're going
to at this point we don't have any apart
from the sto ingress controller there
are no services that have been
discovered on that cluster so we're
going to actually deploy an application
onto the second cluster and show you how
that these applications are discovered
and exposed on the panorama interface so
as you can see here this is a very
popular application it's a I like to
call it the hello world application for
kubernetes but it's a very
representative application it's the book
and for application and it essentially
has four micro services one is the
product page one is the details page
ratings and reviews what I didn't know
and maybe I should just preface this
whole demo with this is the fact that
when I was trying to refresh and apply
policy on this cluster I couldn't quite
explain to Yvonne he asked me the
question hey yeah what's going on why
can't why aren't you able to see all the
data on on certain refreshes and I was
like that's how the application behaves
and I really couldn't have given a good
answer but turns out with all that
visibility I was able to answer the fact
that there is a load balancer and it
actually load balances between different
versions of these microservices and
that's also another benefit
kubernetes right you can have different
versions and you can actually split
traffic between all these different
versions and the fact that I wasn't
applying the right security policy so
it's essentially the fact that we were
playing role reversal where he's a
security team and I was like hey my
application doesn't work I don't know
why it doesn't work but you got to
provide the right security policy I
think it gave me actually great
plausible answer which I bought him so I
said I have no idea you said something
which actually made sense did it I'll
take it but the point here is that I was
actually able to go and look into the
logs and see exactly what was happening
and I noticed that I didn't have the
right security policy but going through
with this demo you see all these
different services and now let's switch
context to panorama
where I can actually show you that we
have discovered a lot of them I call all
these micro services that are running on
this particular customer so I see that I
don't have all my services so you can
actually force a synchronization between
panorama and the kubernetes cluster and
once I do that I see that I have all my
services discovered so what this
essentially allows security teams to do
is they're coming back their application
teams the developers are using
kubernetes gke etc
they've already deployed their
applications but I now as a security sec
ops person need to know exactly what's
going on so that I can enforce the right
security policy so the next thing that
we're going to do here is to show you
how we create those policies so now I
know what services are running and I can
say okay I'm going to script the
security policies so I'm going to pause
here so I just want to spend another few
seconds on exactly what's going on here
I talked about the fact that we're going
to define security policies because Palo
Alto has a lot of enterprise customers
that have a lot of their development
teams moving to micro services
kubernetes etc right so they're used to
defining security policy in a certain
way but we've also talked about the fact
that that's not going to work we need to
be able to reason about namespaces
sources and apply security policy with
that kind of a cadence so what we have
done is we are loving our security
operators to define as I mentioned we're
going to define source groups where we
will add all the
services that are going to initiate the
connections and we're going to a
destination address groups and we're
going to define the services that are
the recipients for those connections and
then we're also going to add certain
other attributes which will allow us to
now enforce this policy so I'm going to
show you how we are creating the source
address group which essentially consider
which is essentially constituted with
all the services that are going to
initiate these connections and I'm going
to add these dynamic address group tags
as I call it and what I've actually done
is I've added all the different services
that I've discovered in my cluster into
my my dad tags and now I can add them as
these are the source services that are
actually going to initiate connections
to destination services and similarly we
do that for the destination groups these
are the tags and this now I'm actually
actually use these tags to define a
security policy so as you can imagine I
have a couple of different services and
I'm going to define a security policy
for the book info application and I also
want to showcase the fact that this is
highly scalable you can all you need to
do is once you define a security policy
you just add tags to all the different
service pairs if you will that you need
to define so we're going to actually
leverage the source dynamic address
group which is called book enforce
source namespace and in the destination
side we're going to add all the
destination services so now you see
we're defining the security policy and
on the right you can see here a service
we can actually define service objects
what the service object can represent is
what is the protocol that is going to be
leveraged for example is it going to be
HTTP is it going to be HTTP 2g RPC etc
so you can define all aspects of your
concur of your service communications
and represent it as a security policy
and I'm actually going to show you that
so you can see that we are actually
referencing referencing the source
namespace which is constituted with all
your source services similarly for the
destination so we have also defined
is the protocol the service its service
HTTP and the action is to allow this
kind of a traffic so once we have done
this we can actually commit this to
panorama and it's ready for consumption
whenever our security adapter is
deployed onto a kubernetes steal cluster
they actually punch in and check in with
panorama to retrieve these policies so
let's take a look at this right now the
the book info application is up and
running and it's accessible
so let's now deploy the Palo Alto
network security adapter from the Google
marketplace so we as you can see I just
wanted to walk you through and show how
you can configure and deploy you see all
your existing clusters you can pick and
choose which cluster you want to deploy
this application into I picked the
panorama IP I pass it in as the endpoint
for where I want to retrieve all my
security policies and then I deploy the
application the Marke Google Marketplace
deploys the application on that cluster
and it's it's up and running at this
point so what happens now is I'm
actually going to switch contexts and
actually show you what are the logs that
when this add with this adapter is
essentially a container that is running
on your kubernetes environment so it's
actually interacted and connected with
the panorama device and its retrieved
the security policies as you can see and
it's translated those security policies
from the Palo Alto Networks language
into into a into a into into policies
that can be applied across your cluster
I'm going to quickly pause here to show
that this is to represent how you can
actually now set up your rules as I told
you so sto needs to know okay hey I have
an adapter here just sitting there
what's it going to do but what you can
see here is now actually say hey I'm
going to define an instance that
characterizes the data that I want to
send to this adapter so this is what we
will leverage from a logging perspective
this is a very subset of the data and
similarly we will also dead define the
rules according to which each tier will
send the
telemetry to our adapter and similar
kind of a posture is applied for your
authorization checks as well so this is
what the Yama file looks like to
actually set up all the plumbing for
mixer to send a lot of the policy checks
and the logging log telemetry to the
Palo Alto Networks adapter and we are
now going to apply this ml file so once
we do this we see that which is what I
told you which is I went through this
you know the rating service is not
available
so I don't have the right security
posture I have a lot of policies defined
but something's missing
so the next thing that I did was I
actually went into the stack driver
interface to say hey let's figure out
what's going on I have fine grained data
and everything that happens so I know
there are authorization checks that
happen and I know for example there was
a there was an an access was allowed but
there were also possibly some accesses
that were denied for example I know that
reviews version 2 there was the reviews
version 2 Service was talking to the
rating service I had no clue but you can
see this is where you can see which
applications which microservices need
access and talking similarly I
immediately jumped to my panorama I
updated my policy to say hey okay I need
to add a new service that needs to be
that needs to initiate connections so
the reviews version 2 service needs to
talk to the rating service I create a
new tag for that I'm just giving you the
whole experience right so forgive the
the pauses here but I now seamlessly it
gets updated to the address book but you
don't have to update your security
policy that's key here you just keep
adding services dynamically to this
address group and it can seamlessly get
applied so we're only manipulating the
address group here we're adding the
reviews version 2 servers we committed
and then these the new policies get
periodically pulled by the adapter as
you can see we have the reviews version
2 that can make up a reviews version 2
can talk to the rating service so now we
have this security policy
once we go here now you're rating
service is available and accessible and
you can see it so this just walks you
through the fact that now you can
actually go back and corroborate hey
okay I actually had this kind of an
access happening I have all the logs
available to me but then the what what I
actually found here the what I'm
actually saying is hey we're not done as
yet there's another abuse version three
that wanted to talk so I'm gonna speed
this up a little bit but we can
similarly you can see the cadence right
you can actually go and add the new
service and everything is up and running
but I just want to reiterate the point
that now you have full visibility into
all the applications and the workloads
and then you know exactly what were the
authorization checks who was talking
whether access was approved or denied
right and all of this data is available
on a stag driver and our cortex data
leak but what I want to actually show
you here is the deployment I'm gonna
sorry about this I'm going to showcase
the deployment of the Palo Alto network
security adapter onto the GK on Prem so
directly from your marketplace you can
actually deploy our adapter onto your
external cluster which is actually
sitting on your on-premise environments
you go to the marketplace page you pick
the adapter you configure it and you've
specified the different deployment
models and it actually seamlessly gets
deployed on to your cluster so once
again I painted that picture of
heterogeneous environments and this is
incredibly valuable because now you have
a unified security posture with all your
data aggregated into either start driver
for example or the Palo Alto Networks
data Lake and then you have a unified
framework to actually deploy policy so
you have discovery and policy
enforcement from a single point so that
kind of wraps up actually in good time
we have a few seconds left but Yvonne
would you like to so just going to you
is that this is all done a live cluster
without any interruptions right there's
the ploidy adapter and you can just
start using it as is so you might
already have our young infrastructure
deployed yeah you wanna you know play
around with these so you want to start
using it you just deployed down and came
on right yeah it's very easy to adopt
and it was and we have all the ammo
files and I get her pages but it's also
been incredibly more easy to deploy now
that it's available on the Google
Marketplace you just point click and
it'll be available and ready to deploy
and please we will be hanging around for
a few minutes sorry we went right up to
our allocated time but we are happy to
answer any questions and thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]